la tnr nous a rejoints sur ce plateau
bonjour à vous au jour petit lob
directeur du bimensuel desk russie vous
êtes ancien à sciences po vous est
notamment l'auteur de cet ouvrage que je
vais citer le monde à l'horizon 2030 la
règle et le désordre aux éditions perrin
merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté
l'invitation de france 24 une première
question pour vous mais vous pouvez
intervenir à tout moment guillaume
quesque il faut comprendre lorsque
vladimir poutine se dit prêt à envoyer
des combattants volontaires on a tous
pensé de manière peut-être un peu
infléchies va des mercenaires de lagence
wagner avec laquelle il y en a déjà il y
en a déjà d'ailleurs qui sont en ukraine
là ils essaient ils se rencontrent
effectivement que ça n'avance pas aussi
vite qu'il ne l'espérait qu'il ya une
résistance extraordinaire du peuple
ukrainien que l'armée russe n'est
probablement pas malgré sa modernisation
cours des dix dernières années si
performante que cela et ils essayent de
créer une sorte de sentiment populaire
patriotique ce qui est complètement à
mon avis perdue d'avancé parce que je
crois que la majorité des russes ne
soutiennent pas cette guerre ne la
comprennent pas même s'il est certes
parti de fraction de la population
endoctrinés par la propagande le fais et
je crois qu'il va y avoir un effet en
retour d'abord effectivement que ces
demandes ne sont pas satisfaites
face à dire qu'il y aura pas vraiment de
volontaires ou des volontaires contre 1
la russie c'est faire ça et angers
contrats complexes qu'on les oblige à
les combattre c'est simple on vous savez
on est quand même dans un état qui
devient de plus en plus non seulement
dictatorial mais sur certains points
même totalitaire on peut aussi menacé
les familles on peut leur dire que les
familles n'auront pas un certain nombre
davantage avantages sociaux accès à un
emploi accès à certains bénéfices
sociaux divers et qu' il ya des moyens
de contraindre d'une certaine manière
ces familles on sait déjà aussi que la
conscription elle-même est extrêmement
dur en russie enfin que l'on de de
sévices sur des appelés en temps normal
j'entends sont extrêmement fréquents et
justement ce propos à propos des des
conscrits nicolas tenzer là un gradé de
l'armée russe a admis pour la première
fois hier l'envoi de ces conscrits
jusqu'à présent par les deux soldats
professionnels et ce que ça veut dire
que là encore la donne pourrait changer
comment il faut l'interpréter mais je
crois qu'il faut il faut l'interpréter
une manière simple c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui d'abord il n'y a pas
assez de soldats quand on regarde les
troupes qui sont là qui sont très
nombreuses déjà un quand même plus de
cent cinquante mille hommes c'est rien
même par rapport à l'ensemble des
troupes russes qui avaient été envoyés
dans un contexte complètement différent
en 1968 en tchécoslovaquie l'ancienne
tchécoslovaquie pour mater si j'ose dire
le printemps drilles déjà à ce moment là
il y avait 250 mille personnes et donc
on a l'impression que voilà que devant
ces échecs parce qu'il ya quand même
beaucoup d'échecs même s'il ya aussi
bien sûr énormément de crimes de guerre
commis par les russes contre la
population civile ukrainien des
bombardements convoi et c est bien il
essaye de jouer en quelque sorte son
va-tout de créer une sentiment de
mobilisation totale et ça veut dire que
les pertes sont considérables dans les
rangs de l'armée russe même si le
chiffre le bilan n'est jamais alors ya
des chiffres qui ont circulé que le
pentagone a lancé entre 2000 et 9000
soldats russes tués c'est très difficile
évidemment aujourd'hui à vérifier à
c'est parfaitement clair mais il y à des
pertes quand même considérable et ça
veut dire aussi que dans la société ça
va avoir que d'ailleurs que ces soldats
soient des contrées où des
professionnels ça va avoir un impact on
se rappelle déjà en 2014 en ukraine
vivaient la mère décédée maires des
associations des maires des soldats
sains qui avait été lancée et kiki qui
dénonçaient ces crimes on a des pauvres
gens qui ne comprennent rien qu'ils sont
là et puis qui rend compte d'ailleurs
c'était frappant de voir ces témoignages
des prisonniers qui ont été faits
prisonniers par les ukrainiens de dire
mais on nous dépeignait des nazis et on
voit des gens qui sont des gens humains
qui nous traitent bien qu'ils nous
donnent qui nous permettent de
téléphoner à nos familles qui nous
donnent des victuailles qui nous donne
de nouveaux vêtements voilà et et tente
où tout se narratif poutinien tombe sur
un écueil qui est celui tout simplement
des fêtes et de la vérité et même si
vous avez tous les réseaux de propagande
en russie qui se met en place même si
c'est de couper lien aux réseaux sociaux
malgré tout les choses fonctionnent en
tout cas dans une grande partie de la
population alors est ce qu'on peut
justement 6e ce grand récit et ce
conditionnement peu s'effilocher
maintenant que la réalité ils la
découvrent aller tout autre en ukraine
lorsque vladimir poutine veut solliciter
des combattants étrangers ce qui peut en
faire venir de syrie du moyen-orient oui
il peut le faire il peut le faire ils
ont il le fait sans doute c'est encore
très difficile à apprécier là aussi les
données sont quand même encore très
sujette à caution il est en tout cas
bien sûr des tchétchènes ça c'est clair
puisque kadirov prête en quelque sorte
c'est ses affidés je dirais sur ses
opérations et qui sont prêts à tout qui
ne respectent pas les lois de la guerre
pas plus que les valider il peut y avoir
effectivement des combattants syrien
c'est tout à fait possible et là aussi
on peut penser que le récit de poutine
sera quand même extraordinairement
affaibli parce que quand on va voir des
personnes alors notamment pour les
tchétchènes qui vont tuer de manière
violente torture et des orthodoxes
ukrainiens ça va faire quelque chose je
pense aussi dans d'autres c'est narratif
hugo qui sera des classiques d'ailleurs
de l'extrême droite en france qui disait
vous avez poutine c'est le défenseur de
la civilisation chrétienne ce genre de
fariboles tout le cas et que là c'est
une guerre entre deux peuples c'est
frappant de voir des requins en juillet
2021 vous souvenez peut-être poutine
avait fait un article en disant nous
sommes un seul peuple les tenues
ukrainiens et russes et en fait on
s'aperçoit que ses frères sont massacrés
aujourd'hui de me rico les villes
russophone ont été bombardées sans
exactement et je te le problème
saucisses et les russophones vous dites
russophone mais vous savez les
russophones ukrainien ils sont d'abord
des ukrainiens même s'il parle le russe
ils ont ils sont pas de sang des
patriotes d'ukrainiens
merci beaucoup merci nicolas tenzer pour